it's Thursday the 12th of September
thank God we got through it yesterday
I'm saying nobody wants to [ __ ]
forget yesterday I never did but anyway
the church is here [ __ ] and the
sponsors today are Vince arrow watches
what time is it it's fall back to work
back to school back to the new you it's
time to grow up and get a real watch
listen in this life you don't got time
to mess around what you wear it says
something about who you are a watch is a
personal statement and then Sarah
watches have a watch for you listen to
me if you want to watch that looks like
a million bucks is made exceptional
craftsmanship and there's a great value
Vince arrow is for you right now the
church family gets a special offer go to
Vince arrow watches comm slash Church
and get you ready for this one 15% off
15% off that's a deal to have that's
Vince arrow watches dot-com slash Church
and pressing code Church CH you are CH
ed check out for your 15% off your order
plus worldwide shipping is always free
one more time go to VIN tetraman Sarah
watches comm slash Church at checkout
for your 15% off don't waste any more
time
get yours today the church is also
brought to you by my bookie listen you
watch that truck the Monday night game
did you see the Texans did you see the
[ __ ] strainers yeah you sitting there
I had the winner get the did you win
money no you didn't you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's time you strapped on a pair and
let's make some [ __ ] dough go to my
bookie dot AG if you're trying to bet on
NFL baseball UFC MMA Bellator Chinese
ping-pong my bookies got it plus they
got a super contest a hundred to enter
five teams two guarantees $100,000
listen right now today before listen
it's Thursday there's got to be a
[ __ ] game on tonight but who's
playing it
matter tonight right now today you're
gonna go to the my boogie dad AG and
you're gonna open up your account what
they're gonna do is they're gonna double
your deposit right now just shoot promos
code Church to get 100 percent bonus on
your initial deposit up to $1,000 I take
care you [ __ ] so go to visit my
bookie dot AG today that's my bookie dot
AG today and don't forget to use promo
code Church when creating your account
to claim the bonus and remember tomorrow
I'm on Instagram and the church is also
brought to you by Dollar Shave Club I've
been at Dollar Shave Club member for
years we had them years ago and I still
[ __ ] love them every month I got a box
in the mail with the essentials raises
toothpaste shampoo don't works it's a
normal it's a no-brainer it's a
no-brainer
no more running to the drugstore to pay
a premium for things you use every day
anyway so do me a favor right now you
can get the quality of Dollar Shave Club
products to the test their ultimate
starter sets have basically everything
you need for an amazing shower [ __ ]
shampoo shave and clean teeth the best
part is you could try it for just $5
Joey what are you talking about 5 hours
just go to right now darlin shave club
Tom slash Church $5 give it a shot take
a chance Columbus dick check this
[ __ ] melee it's [ __ ]
Thursday more than how are you al ago
Eleanor I am so good to be here I wanted
to get John I miss you I always see you
know we'll always cross miss ships in
the night I know I love it and thank you
so much for sending people out to West
Nyack I greatly appreciate that's a
great club it's a great club but a lot
of people walked up and they were like
we've heard you on the church Joey Diaz
did not did not disappoint and I was
like oh that's awesome that's a great
club when it took tracks it wild side of
New Year yeah it's like an I doesn't
attract the Manhattan crowd right the
Brooklyn crowd this the blonde Irish the
bra yeah a lot of Filth Jersey yeah
filthy [ __ ] dead oh my god they
hit people with bottles [ __ ] yeah I love
the [ __ ] food and I act the pizza
joint and the Chinese restaurant that
delivers right to the hotel with egg
rolls they got a barbecue joint that
don't [ __ ] around me and Matt Voltron
old John Hall that [ __ ] weekend up so
happy it worked out and it was Labor Day
weekend which is yeah weekend you know
we did decent numbers man you know it's
crazy that some people just don't want
to go to a [ __ ] another barbecue yeah
you want to go in the air-conditioning
and watch some comedy and laughs come on
Wesley now so I usually don't take that
weekend most people don't they had a
fallout that's how he could not bill
[ __ ] battle yeah but when I heard you
got it I'm like it's an uphill battle
but that's a good area to happen uphill
back that's right there's a lot of
people that just go [ __ ] it what am I
gonna do watch a Yankee game why bother
with now what else is going on I was
just about to [ __ ] on the Yankee know
what is what is the [ __ ] thing would
Bill burr cover that uh not until
January Jesus God I know it takes
forever how did you feel about the shoe
central the shooting was phenomenal if
it comes out as good as it felt I'll be
thrilled
how did you feel I felt great how many
minutes um I did about eight but I think
they're gonna shave it to like six we're
not sure totally prepared I saw when I
saw you how close was that to you
shooting I probably did so many so I
don't know I probably did it a thousand
times that was great it literally felt
like a like if I do that joke the bit
that I used just on there cuz it's like
a little chunk of a piece you know fight
start to say it in my act I get angry
I'm like don't ever say that again
no that's how many times you did it
you're like the dead inside it's out
there get rid of it
it's but I loved it and I'm glad because
it's not dirty
I mean it's edgy but you know I'm still
edgy it's just not dirty so I can use it
on every platform
you can use it you know in clubs call
their like if you have a piece I'm like
yeah here oh this is kind of dirty yeah
well alright well if you could cut that
you don't even like sometimes you just
can't run commercial ads or commercial
for clubs that you're coming up doing
like it I'm doing Harvey's this weekend
and Harvey's they ran my Showtime thing
with dice they're like we don't care we
just beep it you know cuz there's a
couple curses in there that's that's
what people think is dirty which is
funny to me cuz I'm like did they think
Harvey's is pretty basically a clean
Club oh no he used to but clean comedy
club well he saw mention that why he put
me as rated R which is hilarious yes I'm
like yes Jesus I might take my pants off
money I worked at Harvey's in 95 and 96
I think it was different owners but yeah
and then in 97 stanhope put Harvey
together the guy it wasn't as Harvey his
name whatever the guys there
is it new oldest I think yeah okay
that's what somebody told me okay so he
put them together so what the [ __ ] the
big deal do one dirty show once a year
yeah just one okay you believe in clean
time yeah so do i but just one so it was
okay so he would book either me and
Stanhope together yeah and in the year I
cancelled it was I got a movie or
something it was Stan hoping the crazy
kid from Seattle and and I mean like
your head waitress his heads were
blowing up you know for New Year's am I
gonna get arrested with my leg oh no he
says it's no longer this Portland's
expanded a lot yeah you know helium's
down somebody wrote that why can't you
Duke helium I'm like oh you call them he
was a very competitive you know when
helium came into town it you know
Harvey's was making a live listen this a
couple different styles of comedy
yeah once you identify with who you are
in that comedy club as a comedy club
owner you dictate the market there's
comedy clubs that they want Joe Rogan
and Dave Chappelle one yeah and and you
know Lisa Lampanelli and Sebastian and
Joey Diaz and they'll pay the Vig yeah
don't pay the Vig you know they'll pay
it jay leno they'll pay it they want the
best top-notch entertain this stand is
doing it with dice in New York in a
couple weeks and then we're doing then
you have clubs that I respected a lot
because they made me who I am today yeah
that the club owner has a rule and the
rule is I don't give a [ __ ] if you've
been on Leno I don't give a [ __ ] how
many Netflix specials you have I don't
give a [ __ ] have you been on HBO I don't
give a [ __ ] of your mother blue 80
people
it's 1750 with no plane ticket that's
hilarious
most comics go no and then there's a
handful of comics that will say yeah
nobody knows who they are and say their
local comics death phenomenal comics
yeah great comics they have a reason why
they haven't expanded maybe they have a
school teaching job maybe they have a
day job just anything these guys will
travel Thursday Friday Saturday 15 day
great comics with no credits nothing
wrong with that yeah they're still they
still put the time yeah they still did
the open mic somewhere along the line
they decided that California was not in
that future New York was known there
they want to raise their children to
raise their children and these guys
become top notch comics and there's a
home to mmm you know in Houston it used
to be the lab spot laughs okay seems to
be the last stop was the big popular one
the last stop was for the older comics
the kippah Donna's rest in peace the
guys that had their heyday and now their
show got taken off TV and because of
social media
they lost their quality and
yeah so these clubs special.i and
they're phenomenal clubs yeah you just
work with guys that don't want nothing
to do with Hawaii or came to LA mm-hmm
and failed miserably and they're
miserable that's a bad experience but at
least she'll go home if that ever
happens to me I'll never act this way
yeah you know but those clubs were great
clubs yeah maybe the best one look I'll
give you the home and he reached out to
me a couple weeks till the home that had
that phone it was the comic strip in El
Paso oh I've heard great cause I never I
don't know he had a club when I first
met him Bart Reid had a club yeah on the
side of town that was popular okay but
he had a rule I was 15 around all week
comics every once in a while he would
Bend for somebody and maybe do 70 30
yeah maybe if they were a Spanish act
Freddie SOT oh yeah 8020 but besides
that you don't want those guys you don't
want to yeah yeah he didn't even want to
open the door for that and guess what he
was the formula worked in 20 years he
made tons of money
mm-hmm people came and they watched and
they learned and they became fancy us
and then Facebook and everything came
along yeah but there was a dark period
there in comedy oh my god what sign so
gets canceled I don't know how to get
over hold this Jerry no more it's not
like Jerry's tweeting every day what was
he sending our pigeons across the
country I'm still alive Game of Thrones
so yeah the difference that you have
between them yeah yeah you have it you
have a TV show now you're pretty good on
that show you have a couple funny lines
you go on the road while you're doing
the show once that show ends you still
retain that audience absolutely Andrew
social media and Twitter that's a
difference between 20 years ago and now
you know I see what's-his-name on
Twitter a lot now he'll the dad the one
that was in the store that's really
dirty well hey they play the dog Saget
Saget the
- and I see how he's using social media
yeah great on it he's yeah hilarious but
he's always been dirty that's all good
yeah oh she's always been hilarious but
but to go back to the original idea
those rooms are the one set those are
your bread and butter
yeah mm-hmm there's a level of the
Impala like you know what no like what
do you know he's brought you in here
with them yeah you're not even gonna
montreal you didn't do nothing you have
to accept that you have to go that's
fine I'll work a little hard and I'll be
in there next year
so for this year the loony Bin's and yes
house of comedy for all of their
secondary clubs yeah they know it you
know it's a great clubs they preach you
better beat you better than the big
clubs yeah the big clubs take you for
granted
the secondary clubs treat you like a
king they pick you up on Sunday and they
get a breakfast and pick you up they
stick in your Museum see ya it's yeah
whatever [ __ ] great so it's whatever
you want to do with this career you
could do that people yeah I want to do
comedy drama want to do television or
film fine then don't then you don't move
on here yeah come on here yeah you're
just gonna come out here do spots at the
store that might happen it might not
it's definitely not gonna have
everything it's not gonna happen anymore
it's so hard I just had a friend
showcase the other night for Adam he's
like he's terrific
he's great excellent where am I gonna
put him I got 40,000 comics call in a
week like we're oversaturated oversized
everywhere but everybody this is my
problem with that now everybody wants to
be part of the store for years we were
the pieces of [ __ ] in the corner I
wasn't a stand-up then but I would have
to defend it on a regular basis to and
it was ridiculous and now every one of
those [ __ ] are cool you know
I'm better than this guy should be in
front of that girl I should be there go
[ __ ] yourself you weren't in it when we
were grinding and pushing that Club
along keeping it up you were coming
every night there was nobody in the
audience Joe Rogan
every night nobody in that [ __ ]
audience just you guys homework graph
though what made that I heard it was the
Tupac
I heard that no good after the Kennison
thing the club started turning I went to
the dark side
after the innocent after the Kennison
died and that was ninety one or two yes
so after Kennison died I started at 93
okay so this is what's my fault he knew
it all I heard was that the store got
dark what became a darker audience so we
scared away the white people and this is
the truth no no I mean look at me listen
I'm not racist how big of a differences
from having one show of what was it
called Fat Tuesday Tuesday well yeah
so one room made money does that show
I've kept us open for seven years it's
good but the original rule would be dead
yeah because I am the white community
everybody knew not to go to the commies
don't know you're absolutely right and
it's very sad
yeah very sad so all those people don't
let it a I'm not I would I would be with
no Bibles in me I would be there
wouldn't be no belly room show on
Tuesday no no you couldn't give a very
rare right I'm thinking about it no no I
was telling Rogen and the
african-american doorman he opened up
for Joe last week Derek and without
their post it was about three minutes
yeah I'm Mitzi and method of three
minutes you know and also who you are
you know how the system went you didn't
know while you were there and I've been
both tons of comments go what the [ __ ]
she's making me follow this guy that
everybody yeah and she had a plan just
shut it under people disappear because
they didn't want to do a plan
yep and I could have disappeared a
thousand times but I was like nobody
else to take me
Mitzi's vision but yes she wouldn't she
would take a shot she would
people she took a shot with me she loved
oddballs she loved edge [ __ ] laugh
factory hated me
and The Improv barely put up a me but
Richard Cooper was an alkie and from
time to time I'd buy him a drink and he
gave me like a Tuesday 1115 story but it
was the [ __ ] Tuesday night that you
know nobody I was telling Derek I go
Derek that's when you can see how racist
LA was how everybody else not just LA it
didn't really like that night and to
describe to Lee Lee they'd be 450
african-americans in the manor hmm and
500 of them standing outside it was
packed and then there when I tell you
everywhere yeah brothers so people would
be driving from Iowa you know we're here
visiting LA they told us to come to the
counties when they pull up in a jungle
boogie and they're like what the [ __ ] is
this I didn't know cool the gang was
playing this is the wrong play these are
the riot and I'm talking about Oh tell
them that we had those bank-robbers that
hung out at the store oh my god white
guys in st. Louis I used to give us
money over cell phone those black people
were real black people you get killed on
a Tuesday night they're made quarry old
ship behind the bar game you see ya
so like the work around to the audience
that like don't go down on Tuesday no I
think so because here's the thing Fat
Tuesday where people is so big and then
all are there being like maybe eight
people and one night I had this guy and
I remembered his drink he ordered a rare
coffee drink that we had on the back of
the menus that nobody read and Mitch he
named them there were WC Fields Laurel
and Hardy and they were coffee drinks
but it's basically like a Mexican coffee
and Irish coffee just named after famous
comics so this guy got a Joey Brown and
I was like Oh Joey yeah you're the Joey
Brook because nobody says the name so he
goes wow you remember my drink and he
goes you know what forget the coffee
we're gonna get a bottle of champagne
there was three of us and he goes you
know it's really dead in here cuz there
was nobody in the all our and up
by the way I was working the original
room and the main room that's how that
Bo are like yeah that's just an
afterthought the original room
my main focus is the main room so I
bring him a champagne because it's
really dead in here
is it does it pick up let it and I go
well you know everybody's next door the
main room he goes yeah that sounds more
exciting coming over there and I go I'm
just gonna lay this out there it's a
predominantly black show if you're oh if
you're fine with that I mean they're
hilarious they're some of the greatest
color shows world sure and and the
comics were always mixed it wasn't
always just by whatever it was all
everybody oh yeah yeah they put funny up
there's what they did yeah
so I brought him over and I gave him
Mitzi's little booth in the main room
and he had the best time he tipped me
$1,000 so Mitch he called me the next
day by the way I made $1,000 thousand 37
that night thank you Fat Tuesday that
guy didn't come in I went to made 37
dollars anyway Mitch he called me man I
think Jesus Christ what did you do for
that got a credit card
so I had a wait to get paid by the
Comedy Store for it and I go well you
know there was nobody in the original
room and I just brought him over what
else did you do to help I go Vince I
swear to God I remembered his drink he
was an he came in like three other times
and I knew him cuz he tipped heavily and
he said Joey Brown but he had the best
time in Fat Tuesday he was like thank
you so much he tipped the door girls
couldn't guy used to have the door girls
you know I can't think of our name yes
stunning that's right that's right
daughter I mean gorgeous gorgeous girls
yeah so so you know everybody would calm
down you know this beautiful girl one of
my favorite things I saw in Fat Tuesday
was they used to do the birthday dance
do you remember that yes sky Tory would
do the birthday dance and they would go
absolutely ballistic right so this guy
comes up the girls are like gallica
they're in a long table in the back of
the main room
and they were like yeah go up it's your
birthday so the guy walks up he's with
his girlfriend and a bunch of other
people he's on stage and guy's got like
seven other people so they do this dance
and another girl whose birthday it was
starts grinding on the guy that walked
from the back and his girlfriend I was
putting drinks now on their table and
she was like oh this [ __ ] and she was
like [ __ ] you better back up and the
girl started grinding even harder on the
guy this [ __ ] from the back of the main
room she never touched the floor she got
to that [ __ ] stage Joe I [ __ ] you not
she went on every [ __ ] table and beat
the piss out of that girl on stage right
during the show everybody was in shock
she never touched the floor she went on
the tables from the back of it oh Christ
I couldn't even help I had to try a
drink that I just put it down laughing
like what what the [ __ ] were you gonna
do I never saw anybody I was waiting for
her to just take off her weave and go
but she just went all intact and right
to that girl beat the [ __ ] out our guy
was in shock it was amazing I never
really saw any violence or anything bad
well it's just it took him a minute to
break it up but it was just funny how
she didn't [ __ ] touch it the floor
one night I was there and I was talking
to Eddie Griffin admits it oh and they
were telling me a story about two parts
okay he was a freak winner Tupac was at
the store to go see Eddie I want to go
to Fat Tuesday or well we used to have
Monday nights too that Eddie you
surround every room was black on Monday
okay every original room so something
that was the early 90s and there was a
shootout yeah they say if you'd look
across the street yeah it was an old
westerns that I was waiting tables that
night across the street at this shed
what's the hotel across the street uh
it's the sky bar Mondrian mohandro and
House of Blues was almost built it
wasn't built yes no bullet holes yeah in
the wall they were like a Western - ooh
- OH
Western Judas tree God in the original
room but they went out the side door it
was the main room actually you know what
I'm saying it was the main room but they
went out the side door oh I see that
goes right on the Sun yes yeah
front door shoot out this machine and he
would telling me it was in the same bed
he wasn't in the room now what happened
was the next morning Michie called had
him banned them that's the story they
were telling me and he goes what are you
bad what yeah he didn't do anything she
goes because Tupac came in here your
friend and got into a shootout he goes
no now I'm responsible for Tupac got
into a shootout so it was to that degree
the store we had security because
searching because I was cut at that time
at 96 I started making visits away
showcasing I go to Laugh Factory for
Latino laughs best of all yeah came back
in 96 and I still remember driving by
there and see him Richard Pryor yeah
like his name was on the big circle yeah
member and he came back right in a 2000
that's what he came back it has a 196 or
something like that
mm 96 he would come in sporadically in
like 2001 2002 he was doing every Monday
Wednesday and Friday just to feel better
about himself cuz that's all he was
really sick at that point but she we
used to carry him up on stage like it
was kind of sad but it was awesome cuz
he would kind of come to life if that
makes sense while he was up on stage and
I remember watching this big black guy
shred locks in the front he was right in
front of Richard just watch him and
Richards holding court Whoopi Goldberg
Chevy Chase everybody's in there and
this guy just starts crying because he's
realizing this guy's gonna pass like
this is the end of days for the greatest
comic that ever lived through that man's
eyes you don't need me and I was like
putting drinks down like like why my cry
cry what it was a movie like all these
years were you watching this was I
believe it was calm
radar never yes they we were talking
about podcasting in the podcasting world
and now you guys sucked me in the Sun
for Texas is [ __ ] now acting was
such an acting schools was such a scam
and my wife brought I remember on
Freddie and Eleanor signed
well Freddie quit because of it yeah
Sherri Shepherd quit because of it the
Baba was shocked we were all in there
but it's really weird how you was stand
up ever on your radar no and and like
you're saying watching the great even
Eddie Griffin like every night when we
had those Monday nights that was the
early 90s that that shoot out was like
94 95
because 94 maybe because it they got rid
of it right away
and that night of the shootout we had
locked everybody in the office Mitty
included she was there so we get
everybody in the office right and I'm
fresh out of South Philly so I'm still
half a hood rat and you know I'm
strapped I'm I'm a mess because I I was
thinking the riots you know I was
dealing with like coming in - oh they
have riots whatever just pay attention
keep your head up so when that shootout
happened I'm like holy [ __ ] it's in the
place I work my mother's gonna kill me
she told me to not do that not come here
because of this and like South Philly's
any better anyway so we so we're in the
office everybody's in I'm making sure
everybody's there and mitts he looks at
me and she's like go out and get me a
Courvoisier I'm like what he's shootin
she's like just go get it and she's
shaking like a leaf I'm like all right
I'm gonna come back with a [ __ ] bullet
and see like I'm a nervous wreck like
look at but she's looking at me cuz I'm
like the tough girl whatever from South
Philly but I still don't want to be in
the middle of a shootout [ __ ] like so I
remember like looking under the cabinets
for kvasir cuz mr. Pete locked
everything they were all issued ins and
the bartender out she sent me out I'm
like [ __ ] a whole look but I got her
little Courvoisier all nervous like
looking behind me and I brought Monty
aged 95 like night I was Miss iya
Rogan's
yeah yep Martin was always there Chris
Rock I know like in 93 I met Chris Rock
because my first ex-fiance was his agent
yeah so Billy we were friends before we
started dating but he was always at the
store and you'd be like hey Chris is
doing a show I remember Chris like
pulling out a sandwich board with his
picture on it to put on the sidewalk so
people would come in to the LR to see
him I'm 93 like crazy Chappelle - he was
always there but he was underage and he
was 20 19 or 20 something like that 93
was 93 the Robin Hood melon tights he
may be just turning 21 cuz you just used
to sit on the patio and smoke weed until
he was loud on no [ __ ] yeah he might
he's like 44 are you serious he's 43 or
44 yeah I'm almost positive right 46 46
oh look like I made him younger so in 93
he's 20 years born in say August of 73
mm-hmm so I just I remember being like
I'm gonna go in but because the other
underage people we have were Aries
Spears and Jenica burger
do you remember Janica she was in and
out because they were both 19 and Aries
went on stage and [ __ ] on her and she
waited for him she was little she grew
up in LA she was a little hood rat she
was funny and she waited for him and
when he got off she [ __ ] attacked him
and they had a fistfight on the back of
the stairs in the original room it was
probably the best thing I've ever seen
again I couldn't help because I was
laughing too hard sorry it's just funny
what a white girl just sex but they were
the same age so mitzi ban them both and
they not neither one Aires would do Fat
Tuesday but he never did the or again is
that weird yeah I told Aires and he goes
yeah they banned me cause I'm black I'm
like
why they've been Jenica them she's white
he goes oh she got Pam like he didn't
know all those years he just never came
back he just assumed she ever come back
no and genic is huge she works she was
on shameless the past couple of years
she's an actress she's been in a lot of
[ __ ]
and she's also a producer I always want
to get her on The Comedy Store podcast
because she literally was there for like
maybe eight months maybe a year but she
was a funny stand-up and she was just a
young girl young girl 19 years old but
Aires - Aires you know we know him he
stayed in the comedy game obviously but
it's just like funny how like Janica
knowing you'd have to google her to
figure out who she is Dave Chappelle
smokin prime that was my favorite cuz he
was the nicest guy admits you really
liked him like if he was in town there
was a few guys she loved that would come
from New York that she would always
automatically put on Chappelle was one
Jeff Ross was one as hell she liked BER
she didn't it took her a long time to
like BER which is weird to make some be
like like you don't even like mushy
would do that but I think the darkness
started cuz her health was declining and
she wasn't as involved the Monday nights
went away Fat Tuesday started up and
that was one night a week but we were
still not getting anything on Fridays
and Saturdays remember the main room was
only open on Saturdays when I first
started there was two shows in the manor
of Friday Saturday and or there was
three shows we used to do a seven a 10
and a 12 always every night of Friday
and Saturday over so that we used to
have to change our shirts and the middle
shifts like very first start at 93 but
then that went all the way down to one
then it went down to and Terry will tell
you that was like because when she came
it was really bad unfortunately we would
have we used to have like three girls in
the original room waiting tables and
then sometimes what prior we would have
four but mitzi only like three of us
like she only trusts it three of us so
she got rid of the fourth one but you
know it's just too clustered
then it went down to two and then I went
down to one one person waiting in a
whole room waiting tables
that's how slow it was so it was you
know and we had some great nights some
bad nights we had like Rogen always says
nobody was in there and I'm like I she's
right to an accept good from a comics
point of view but as a waitress I would
have been homeless like I was making
money I obvious you know we were talking
about so I paid rent you know night we
also spoke about the change
yeah but I think you guys are the change
I got to be on now no no Adam taking it
getting rid of Tommy Adam taking over
making those calls on like Spade and you
know getting a little bit more of a
comedy element versus this development
thing that minty used to do and she
would just pass people and forget and
just keep putting them on the lineup
because obviously her health was
declining and she wasn't fully aware of
what she was doing and the lineups we
joke about how she we would hand it in
to her like the comics would call in and
she wouldn't get past the A's so the
lineups would be I met a med Aron Kader
like she just go down the first thing
like she wouldn't flip through
alphabetically all the comics so we were
like [ __ ] we have to write it different
you know anything like it happened a lot
that the town coordinators Duncan when
he was like I got to get out of here
this is crazy so he quit and then you
know we got Tommy got moved up and Tommy
figured out how like just putting his
favorites in front of her or whatever
and then getting rid of what he didn't
like so it was his fucked-up power then
once they got rid of him Adam taking
over and putting on you know solid
hard-hitting comics and Eric Anderson
also the he's the vice president of the
Comedy Store which hasn't been a title
since Mike Becker when it was really run
in the 80s and not early 90s you know so
Eric Anderson coming in really also
clean some [ __ ] up and then you guys
with the podcast I gotta be honest Joe
Rogan Joe Diaz you guys Marc Maron Greg
Fitzsimmons and then just people hitting
you know we had the Chelsea Peretti's
Leslie Jones you know all those great
comics that were just kind of like not
being recognized
daliyah sebastian wit me wit me Eliza
o fortune team start like seriously
grown comics at the store love that and
they were there through the [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah Leslie was really there through
this [ __ ] Monday night was yeah it was
dead yeah Monday night cuz we had open
mic on Sunday Monday I ever walked in
that there was six people in the
audience done Barris was onstage Eddie
Griffin was there with to luck the black
guy from the show got a Harlem that
movie the lake about Eddie Griffin I
have so many great memory I was so
impressed by seen any Griffin he was a
Erykah Badu for a while yeah cuz I loved
him and though at that time it was
Monday's with men's a mullet yeah
Tuesday's the original one was dead I
think I got three spots at Fat Tuesday
the last time I bombed really hard they
were like this hey they were a tough on
they were tough audience and then
Wednesday you had the original room
Wednesday's was thirty people yeah yeah
Thursday's was sixty to eighty Friday it
was good
Saturday's was good mmm-hmm and then
Sunday's was the open mic and they were
they were family night yeah it was like
go on date spaghetti on yeah yeah Joe's
there wasn't a big audience but you got
to see everybody hmm you got the see
people didn't get spots during the week
yes sunday was always up a little bit so
it was kind of a weird night but I
always enjoyed it because the stars
weren't that yeah it was fun so it was
our night yeah you know what
aye sir comics just throwing Heat what
will happen
what happened was oh yeah you gotta go
thin flow heat what happened was a lot
of delusional 'z come out on the
ballooning um uh look might you had the
crazy guy yeah that's my favorite crazy
guys that Mitzi didn't really want
around so she passed them but he passed
this don't get stung and she decided I
don't want them around but she didn't
have the balls to say Jan so they would
come up every night and get cocktails
there were 20 of them mm-hmm it was one
guy able to make you a Michael something
he cried the Blues exactly Michael pace
but suddenly them something what I was I
know anything I just don't want to say
what's it for
what's the blonde the bartender what's
the bartender from Boston the the
manager from Boston that was really
small and cute she's on Facebook now she
was the manager and she was such a sweet
girl oh yes Janet Janet Janet Janet
south wall yes
everybody would attack her and she was
so little is that one spot and she would
just be like mental I can you talk to
Missy for ba-ba-ba-ba-ba so then I got
the job of hosting on Sundays and at
first I felt compassion for them but
after a few months I realized like you
yeah because they were paying the
[ __ ] asses and at that point I would
look at them and go they would come to
me and complain to me about
Mitzi's knocking response I don't know
what to do why are you getting spots and
I would have to [ __ ] talk him off the
ledge I can't listen it's not getting
[ __ ] spots go somewhere else go
somewhere else but instead we don't want
to go no often I don't know what the
[ __ ] to tell you yeah they got so
annoying it was like oh eight of them
that was and they they get there on
Sunday at eight in the morning and sign
up so they knew they were gonna be
number one until I got there so I would
call down there at five and I go read me
the list yeah
and they'd read me a list let go no
that's
not happening is missing Lebanon that
tonight yes she is that's not gonna
happen
and I got on the phone I call Angier and
are you busy yeah what's up how would
you like to do an hour tonight
which of the ten o'clock sharp you do a
[ __ ] hour really even go I'll be there
and I would also made them yeah yeah
look at their schedules and I would see
when they were home on Sundays and I
call it at 5:00 what are you doing
tonight
come bump these do me a favor come at
ten
Eddie do the joke about the flying the
tree with Ben Franklin inventing cocaine
but doing it the two-hour mark so I
would basically go up there I would get
my [ __ ] off I would get my tan along $25
I get my ten off of ebay and kill to
cover my next weeks early cuz you had a
cover I had to make sure I got coffee
that's right it's Fox next week so I got
to blow up this [ __ ] room
yeah so I will go up there blowing up
for eight minutes and then bring Eddie
Griffin and all those poor guys would
just be in the back heartbroken and they
would come up to me and say how long do
you think he's gonna do like tell him
ten minutes sit around and I go outside
oh and at the one hour mark they would
start to break and I would always have a
backup somebody would hang them oh then
the thing would switch again and I blame
it on Mitzi yeah always playing well I
get the list go inside their names
oh yeah just let scratch your names
putting this guy for number and I'm this
cuz I movement wanna see him I'd moved
this guy the 78 do you think there's
like a group of like 10 guys who just
hate you know there's about 50 of them
that hate me know if you didn't come if
you didn't get the hint I was I was
trying to help you I'm not hurting your
feelings I was trying to tell you that
listening she she just did the list yeah
because when she walked in she would
look at that list and look at it go
yeah I could surged your love was first
you could have a heart attack she was
hurt your lover first there was just
[ __ ] she didn't wanna love you
jobs ticket
I love surgeon I love sir telling you
the truth guys because it was her she
did not want Serge you're going up first
jumping up and down she did not want
come from Calcutta yeah come from
Calcutta
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes Lopez was Emma Santa
no parking in my parking and then the
whole [ __ ] deal hilarious this was
going on for months people killing each
other of a parking lot and you're just
trying to regulate the thing so you
don't get fired you know like I don't
get it go in the parking lot kill each
other eight guys they would I felt bad
for them they were great comics yeah
it's time to move on from the store one
thing I appreciated about Adam I was
there the night when they got have
played the vinyl it was gonna play the
harmonica Charlie Fleischer I just
thought about I had said a prayer for
him I thought about when that would be
my dad the talent coordinator would come
up to me and say Joey you're not
relevant normal do you pray cuz I do
that I know before they come up to you
but like I pray that I I recognize yes I
will my down I will before they guy will
I'm critical of everything you say I
don't I read my main line is I'd rather
walk out on my feet then crawling on my
knees
exactly okay when the Tommy situation
when that went down
I knew two things were gonna happen
there was gonna be two things that the
Tommy situation was a coked-out Joe Diaz
coked-out Joe Diaz with 26 years of
cocaine under his belt where his [ __ ]
thinking wasn't that sharp probably one
thing I'm gonna go down there one night
and I'm gonna take two of those
[ __ ] this grab one by this side of
the head the other one or the other side
just banging their heads together to one
of them dies I do this was the yeah
really gonna happen that's how he felt
they were on my territory I never I'm
not a gang member
I don't belong to the Mafia I don't
belong to anything I'm a comic and I'm a
Comedy Store comic and they were causing
problem on my ass you're a red or black
and at that time I wasn't healthy enough
mentally to take on that war
I wasn't ready comically to take on that
war I just wasn't prepared I was too
much of a drug addict they came up to me
pretty much both of those jerk-offs came
up to me and told me to my face they're
like when Joe Rogan ends the man of
whatever tour the real men of comedy oh
yeah yeah 45 minutes is gonna stop up
here I'm doing 45 is gonna stop and the
other jerk-off with the hat on was next
to mine is that well yeah yeah sorry
right he's gonna go down you're at yes
and I looked at him when I go okay and I
went home that night and I did not
understand how I got home that night
that they were it was a declaration of
war what they were doing absolutely and
that's okay ten I almost got in the car
and went back there because Tommy had no
right to do that and it's like a Perillo
and that's [ __ ] both of them was
sucking each other's dick yeah [ __ ]
oh and there was there was like four or
five John's family I could see I could
see the thing building I could see where
it was going
even though I was coked down even though
my judgment was not on I could tell that
one point I saw two things the first one
was the night that Paulie through Joe
out because of this the worst thing I've
ever seen yeah Friday night when I
thought I turned my back so I will have
to live the life that best
that's how slick I am cuz I thought Joe
was definitely gonna hit Paulie and
other guy yeah he's grown weed now his
mother still comes to the store sweet
Dean oh you can't come here and do that
I don't heaven be we're gonna go down
and then I attack Dean well that's yeah
one of my cocaine rages I went down he's
not gonna feel anything anyway Dean's a
great no we love D we tease him all that
that's a great guy we in fact he sent me
weed he's grown up in Afghanistan he's a
great guy he's a great sucked into and
sucked into world so one night he came
up to me and I wouldn't have to Dean
very unprofessionally in one of my drug
Hayes's and I'll not forget that I went
off on him I said a bunch of things yeah
frustrated I wasn't getting nowhere I
was sick and tired of doing coke and
poor Steve no he was just a young kid
and I'd looked at Steve burn and he's
such a sweetheart of a man he could tell
nicest guy and I still level what I
uttered what I go I looked at him and I
go you don't [ __ ] get it
that one [ __ ] [ __ ] she dies this
place is done thinking we're gonna be
filled up with [ __ ] like that that's
what my cocaine mind was well you
weren't wrong if they didn't know that I
got in my car laughter I said my days
down there a numbered once I got into it
with him
and then I got into it with the other I
didn't get into what the other guys they
came and gave me like a slight threat
yeah I had a package in my pocket I was
just happy I was getting a spot see in
those days tommy was giving me 1245 spot
yeah what's Rogan started getting pull
rogue listen no I want Joey in front of
me yeah
and that really pissed people off yeah
that really you know and listen people
had the right to get this dog just when
i'm tanja the store at that time was the
ship being run by four or five guys they
do whatever they want
Eddie Pauly Andrew Rogan it was like
five guys that would get a little bit
off-course they we were forgotten
why we're here for anyway right this is
15 minutes we're a family nobody's here
to do better than a bond exactly a
couple you know it started getting at
people come in and do 80 minutes and do
four hours and that's disrespect there
was comics that quit because of that
like Nancy pimento the girl who created
shameless she was a great comic she was
also the first writer female writer on
South Park with Trey Parker and those
guys she created shameless like she's
the head writer of shameless I don't
know if she created it but she's one of
the head writers on that show she one of
my favorite people in the balloon I've
had her I'm trying to get on the store
podcast but how great she opened my kurz
but she quit because Mooney every time
she had a showcase Mooney would come in
and bumper so they would not stay to see
her and then she sold her movie sweetest
thing right she's so yeah right she's
brilliant she's still around she just
says to do stand-up she's you know
wealthy yes I mean like in a good way
though she channels at a different way
she writes you know and she's I think
she just sold another show cuz shameless
is ending shameless is a great show
she's been writing on that since the
beginning to concoct it for me
I love it it's too I do the black dude
the chick with the hair to pre the
presentation me William H Macy's
characters the best character I've ever
seen on television that's great better
than Tony Soprano that room
know that an alcoholic white guy who's
too smart
I love oh I love it it's different way
what came with his country that they'd
get into school well yeah she's gone for
a month if I was that judge I give her
six months but I would - I agree
likewise as she walks on there were six
months if she gets she has another dog's
age but something very interesting
happened yesterday every day wah wah
that nobody caught on there sweeping it
under the carpet what happened to just
like your kids [ __ ] and figure it out
it's [ __ ] man interesting happening
what lynn swann retired as the head
athletic director of USC that's not good
hmm that's not good did you hear this
new [ __ ] defense mm-hmm that she not
only gave money to them but she also
gave money to us C's Department and she
thought she was building a building all
of a sudden out of nowhere there's Lynn
Swann has never done a thing that's been
negative he quit as athletic director of
USC ripoli [ __ ] put it on the front page
right they buried it about I didn't know
it look what happened yesterday guys
nobody remembers anybody remember a guy
by the name of Todd Marinovich well Todd
Marinovich was a quarterback who played
for maybe UFC a Stanford or one of those
I may be wrong and Todd Marinovich was a
YCL civilian oh yeah tremendous
quarterback not the best but you go to
the NFL let me tell you this story rich
of his father has become a really good
trainer right now he's helping jenamae
people I know he was about 10 years ago
hey years ago he was a you as alignment
this is the beginning man a quarterback
or alignment well no hold on he
former quarterback for the NFL endless
CFL looking at in football a CFL yeah
okay he played for the LA Raiders okay
yeah what college what college if he
came from the CFL um USC listen he
played for UFC he was touted to go hi
you ready ready
bad I've had one day quickest dick one
day he was really dumb idea one day he
was riding his bicycle arm better
speeches somewhere in this area
people could correct me that's honest a
the story yeah and he got mysteriously
pulled over by the cops and they found a
gram of coke in his sock so the word on
the street was that the Raiders planted
it so he could go lower in the draft and
they could draft because that was now
Davis so look what happens yesterday
everybody's jumping up and down and
Tonio brown yeah like they didn't know
that like nobody knew the rain has had
that hastened of course
abso-fucking-lutely they had that a
salutely day what would they they waited
oh he's signed look at him flying like a
bird oh yeah wait three signs the
contract and we dropped that I'm Lu
England listen NFL I said that at you
NFL has set of security people liaison
of course [ __ ] feelings a lot of people
don't have their own liaisons yeah and
they do like this weekend not entourage
ballers Oh baller here you will not this
year because they got that [ __ ] I
haven't watched I haven't watched yeah
ain't great it's just an occasional
[ __ ] white people now in Hollywood
it's great no it's not I was into it I
just you watching from seventh day there
you go okay now I could watch 60 minutes
and nothing like a piece of [ __ ] up oh
there didn't the Sopranos what's your
favorite show
cuz Sopranos to me wrote them all like
that's
greatest the wire to me to me it goes as
waters the greatest Tommy of all time is
the honeymooners
a the comedy 101 where the funny guy and
the guy next to him I was just playing
off restraint got hurt yeah ii tight
comes the Odd Couple I love all that
[ __ ] oh yeah it's not like saying I live
I don't give a [ __ ] who the cast I'm
with you on that I'm likely to pop
culture to play it out yeah Benny Hill
white pink with any ailment I could cry
okay honey
but were they you know for a guy like me
what changed my life Ricky Ricardo I put
it down yesterday and all things Cuban
sure if it wasn't for Desi Arnaz I
wouldn't know I wouldn't I put it just
like this in a Cuban expression you are
gonna mess I gonna be balling and see
and Desi Arnaz let it be known you could
do whatever the [ __ ] you wanted nice
brilliant
it took CBI Ernie was married to Lucy
for 10 years
yeah well CBS would even consider him
putting him on like he fought batteries
created that can already created they
[ __ ] three cameras while all these
[ __ ] stand up guys over there
why is that guy Stanley why don't we see
him do a camera a Cuban had a [ __ ]
put that together so if any of you
studios he's the only old he'll just
yeah a poly a Cuban once a watch every
angle he covered the spread yeah we got
on the topic why don't we do table of
Lucy but I didn't watch TV for a long
[ __ ] time
yeah once again two comedies no peevish
well yeah 91 that was the end of
baseball football
I still watch sports but I didn't get
into shows and tell Serrano once I got
the copy then I was in Cleveland doing
the weekend coked up I don't know what
the [ __ ] I was working to Cleveland
improv okay
and I went back
to the room I got some coke and I went
back to the it wasn't a hotel room was a
condo across the street from cars the
Haven of death the bar had everything
heroin was sugar the postseason for the
Rican hookers happy pills you know so I
[ __ ] went back up and I quote like
episode three of The Sopranos and I was
pissed I was when I saw that number
that's the show they're talking about Oh
cuz you weren't on it no oh no I I was
in New York I went to my buddy's he I
had a spot from the latinum in the old
days well no because you weren't doing
comedy in the old days The Laugh Factory
made tapes so I made a tape but the
problem with the tape was the quality
was good but the volume was wow yeah you
had a go guess so I figured out a guy
what's that post offices sunset you make
the rad Wilcox yes I know exactly what
you're talking about
that he could take the volume and raise
alone so I finally got this great tape
together was like a [ __ ] 18 minute
tape how hard is it to get an 18 minute
tape I got the tape New York I made
duplicates I called my manager and
Phillips that morning and I go what do
you want they're doing he goes all right
you have a couple jobs to go drop the
tape off at this place go drop a tape of
Global Entertainment okay Wabble at that
time boom governors yeah okay booked
like six or seven oh and they also have
a Jimmy yeah yeah they also an agency
who sent you out took four auditions
they had a bunch of people okay so I
went to global and dropped off at eight
that was the time that's why I totally
that's why I made one of those lean
mistakes I was in Jersey and I agreed to
a guest spot at the seven o'clock show
in Long Island
oh boy oh boy I would have done the same
well yeah deep in the jungle and I
barely made it
dido buying you know cuz now you're
there I've made it yeah yeah you're next
well guess what's gonna happen I went
all the way three hours to die a slow
death and when I got off five minutes
and it's so crazy because you go to this
[ __ ] know when you get off you don't
even bother as to the people yeah I
don't know I ate a bag of dicks thank
you don't you don't pay for guests but
don't worry thank my god oh I dropped
the tape at every place and he also told
me he goes write this address down drop
your tape off there's this new show The
Sopranos and they're looking for guys
like you and I drop the three tapes off
and I got lazy telling I don't want to
go in for a salt show about singing and
I never wanted anything off can you
believe that the only reason I'm
laughing is because wheels told
Sebastian that he was in a spin-off of
The Sopranos called the baritones
Sebastian went home and told his family
but he knows a guy who's gonna be on the
spin-off no he told it you can listen to
it on the comedy star podcast because he
told that story we mean Rick were dying
so excited cuz wheel solimene would get
him on the baritones if you know leaving
if you notice one good thing happened
about the Sabath about the successes of
bash I love this is you know what the
success is a passion did for us what we
didn't have to put up with no more
knuckle and Italians he knows for 10
years we had a string of knucklehead
Italians in this town yes you didn't go
to auditions no I went but I they would
audition for Mitzi not the ones oh yeah
you got all you got all those
knuckleheads but what I had
two directions in the acting world I
would walk in and be Frank Stallone oh
okay that's the first more man I had to
put up with no cash I love friends
people talking to Frank there's nothing
to talk to Frank about fact the other
night I watched the Rocky movie and it
was him singing at the end you got an
Oscar rat god-awful that Wow
the other one oh the Bee Gees oh not the
[ __ ] Bee Gees I'm sorry it's one name
oh all right I know is the end of Rambo
I was gonna say also not sure I know my
shin I know my Stallone's it's my pseudo
brother Alliance is god-awful Oh Frank
Stallone ever told to me anything he's
good oh he's not levitate I'll send it
to you please leave me alone
before the podcast started enjoy what
you were just saying how like all it is
is sticking it out like you said Greg
Garcia was an extra on a TV show
twenty-something years ago three years
Oh I mean Andy no Greg Garcia just
posted today Greg Garcia the director of
[ __ ] 20 shows if you don't know Greg
guy sees you should be ashamed of
yourself it's it's I'm mixing it 23
years ago he was an extra on my load to
100 yes so I know - oh yeah so now today
he's he has three shows the syndication
yeah Mazhar oh [ __ ] it yes show with the
gay guy that was trying to be straight
and the other one that he did the Fox
he's got three shows yes I know exactly
who are you talking about now so like
the reason I'm bringing it up is I went
to a comedy world by accident okay I
went to an open like two nights ago with
a casino and he we were joking cuz right
but when we were sitting there a guy
went up with a chicken costume on the
joke did his entire thing about being a
chicken he's like okay I had to go and
be sense [ __ ] through the chicken guy
like how many guys will stick through it
Ian and be like the crazy people be like
the Franks know like how many people
will well wait it out well Frank
Stallone had a brother why he might be
about example dick he also got an Oscar
for a song so he's not like he didn't do
anything brother
there are some crazy people who just
stick it out and just remain crazy don't
get anywhere a hell yeah like just one
day night at the Commerce oh I thought
you were gonna say Robert William I
provide but yeah go there on a turn as
sad as it sounds I love Ralphie to death
he was my brother Lana Turner
yes she's I've done some showcases
somebody told me two nights ago that
they saw and that she should have taken
my advice to sell both houses and to
Florida
close to a family and go on the cruise
ships yeah she's good cruise ship yeah
she's perfect for the cruise ship they
have radar shows and family shows and
that would have saved or a lot of time
and aggravation because at one point I
mean again listen nobody wants to give
up right well I'm gonna be how hard
would it be 2009 I married Terry I was
off to blow and I started thinking about
it I got a call from the funny bone some
lady who we feel that because you open
for Joe they they gave me a number and I
said I'll do that if I don't have to
work Sundays and they said you have to
work Sundays I said I don't want to do
it I lived up the corner the frail and I
said I'm gonna get a job selling cars
over here I wasn't doing spots at the
store yeah this was during the Rogen
2010 at Oakland Wow
broken head we should work for me that
were easy Rogan does it easy there's no
drama don't get the bad note war
Buster's just straight-up gangster
famous dice and I was pretty content
I knew my standing I knew I wasn't one
of the boys in the circle there was
never gonna be a picture of me at the
improv we're gonna be I'm with you never
gonna be on a Comedy Central show
there's things that you accept
never gonna be on Fallon
that we're gonna be Anna Letterman cha
I'm never gonna be on this you know and
you have to accept him you know when I
got into comedy the this fifth year I
heard all the rumors about television
and what you needed and at that time at
the five-year mark
I really no I didn't wanna do lot of me
yeah I had just read too many books on
Lenny Bruce and Richard Pryor and said
renegades that real sand all the just to
rule so you know what I don't adjust the
rules in modern day
I'm not going to definitely adjust to
them in time for him yeah I knew right
off the bat I had you have to be that
honest with yourself and know what's
going to and what's not gonna work for
you and then comes the main world in
your life which is called adapt you
adapt to whatever they put in front of
you
Mick Jagger said it best you don't get
what you want what you get but you get
what you need
yeah if you really put it on to the
universe listen lord I just need twenty
two hundred a month take care my wife
and to keep me in a couple hot dogs like
a smoke pot and all I need to do is that
I don't want to be I don't want to
become sorry it could be done you could
work for that goal there's tons of
comedy yeah clubs that that there's
always a career in comedy don't tell me
there is no it's never met though
they're cheap event oh you know what I
met Nancy pimento punch punch twine San
Francisco really 1996 drove down from
Seattle you know 11 hours do a guest set
you know I was doing comedy guest set in
San Francisco
sleeping on the [ __ ] car and I went
right back to the Seattle you know
hilarious and I met Nancy pimento I met
oh my god this probably for people I'm
still friends on from that particular
night and then I saw Nancy momento at
the improv
she was part of the fun group we call it
fun bunch Doug Benson Oh different about
different crew I'm not together
see you know more
you know orphans out that time to check
that a goat cheese with the omelets that
came on the show I hope so what's the
know she used to be on the [ __ ]
Chelsea Handler's show she's the fashion
a Leawood chick Heather McDonald she
never was a store girl but I am she was
so is pimento right but they used to do
pimento was a store girl
Mitsy past what she would hang out this
door with the nice white people she was
good with the group she was in a little
slick of guys right that will go on the
right direction yeah they were gone
that's why she ended up writing that
script yeah but I know Nancy pimento
from 96 that's amazing the San Francisco
punchline we walk dishing for the San
Francisco Comedy Competition oh okay so
you went not just for a guest spot you
it was a big oh no she's no [ __ ]
guest in those days but you said I 11
hours for a guest by gunpei yeah
everything is yours yeah the whole
package is yours
welcome to the real world there ain't
nothing the Bluebird to happen the same
thing that still exists that's the York
to do basically an audition of no choice
wait Lana yeah and for Jenny McCarthy
I think she didn't like me I'm gonna go
with she didn't like me I had a great
set by the way Oh [ __ ] on there's
some people that say no I know my
limitations I listen Netflix is never
gonna give me a special you should have
tears on my eyes
none why would they not give you a
special you're generating you look like
it propelled a whole nother you're doing
another one but it wasn't the only one
they're doing yes all of you Ju yes Liza
I understand behind or nothing didn't
really matter but that's when my point
is you have to accept the little things
in your career and they make you
stronger yeah that's it you're not gonna
be invited fair reason you're not gonna
be one
boys you're not gonna be invited for the
oh yeah yeah tell thanks Danny you know
how bad I want to go to Montreal as bad
as I want ten guys to rape me in the
bathroom okay I knew that in 1999 I was
that smart to know that nice yeah I
agree I don't I gotta get on a plane in
LA with these same morons with these
same jack logs I see four nights a week
and go to Montreal to now see them in
their element and a bar with their fight
they're fake suits on and all the
[ __ ] I'd rather not go it would be
the last place I'd want to go I'm the
last how many of those things that
sometimes got like I tell my yeah
something happened in my house last week
my rock my wife wanted to be involved in
the school thing you know and she wanted
to run for something now me well I kept
my mouth shut I'll interfere their
affairs like that but I know my wife I
know Terry I know that I have a little
bit of money put away
I put away every month sometimes I go on
the road and they say that we do you
want your travel money and I go give it
to me in cash yeah take that cash and I
put in a bank account that nobody knows
about smart because I didn't well now
they know
but ya know that one day I'm gonna hear
the door slam and I'm gonna hear
stomping how she stomps when she's glad
she's gonna come up to me and she's
gonna say we're gonna pull her out of
that [ __ ] school
I hate those [ __ ] snowflakes I feel
it comin yeah yeah the fact it was
really weak cuz I had to go to the beach
delray sighs yeah and on the way back I
drove past Immaculate Heart mm-hmm
sunset goes up the AFI yeah yeah I have
a Jewish friend who sends his daughter
there he's like it's a great school the
rest of Catholics they get the girls in
order they don't the way uniforms very
progressive and I already said you know
what that's 35 grand a year I'm left to
suck 10 dicks to make 35 grand but I
already feel yeah I really let her know
I go you don't know this then you don't
know you
with you for 20 years yeah yeah yeah any
day now any day what's that song but I
don't know what it is yeah yeah any
dynamic won't be wrong I won't be afraid
any day now
she's gonna walk Murphy saying mommy but
no mommy but I want to stay there she's
gonna come in because they're already
happened last year she went to pick her
up one day and they couldn't find mercy
and peak and the principal was like well
and Terry wet Oh get out of my face and
wet weather we got the kid and then the
way out the principal's like mrs. Diaz
we won't explain T and she's like I told
you to get out of my face I just told
she robbers she's already know my wife
yeah she's gonna come you know where
yeah this is just a few weeks tonight
we'll go to a PTA thing I'm dead for
that I gotta go to bring your three
Cuban cameras I'm going from every
anchor the self-defense class at 4:00
and then we're gonna get her warmed up
change perfect
I'll pop in the hundred there's no way
he's going so no I might think you would
be just so you can see what I listed
remember that's the case remember the
wooden cattle walk up to you and go hi
how you doing yeah are you doing good
tonight yet do you feel are you married
yeah I want you to remember this face
yeah yeah eventually you want come to
this pecan party like a tree you walk
out there like [ __ ] that I'll never deal
with those [ __ ] snow face again so
anyway my ran for this thing is she's
very excited and last Tuesday when she
came home I saw she was kind of sad they
took her you like yes
walked her off the ledge I took her for
coffee and we talked about it and I told
I said listen I learned something with
if I learned something the biggest
lesson I learned in comedy that is part
of life this for you people too is
sometimes you want something you want it
so bad you could taste it but you don't
get it and you're pissed at people and
you're angry and you hate the world and
you think your life is over
oh yeah my life is over
guess what some nine out of ten God did
you a favor
trust me I'm here to tell you I'm not
John irreligious you don't see me with a
cross on my neck you don't see these
freaks on the Bible yeah I'm telling you
that if you're a good person karma will
avoid you eyelets I never forget there
was a movie [ __ ] made you know [ __ ]
off what's the Will Smith why are you
going [ __ ] up a myth made a movie that
when I read the script it was so
powerful the tears are running down my
eyes oh I know
page 15 Pursuit of Happyness a
know-it-all was about him I forget what
the [ __ ] that was but reading the script
I didn't even sleep that night
Wow I knew the part I wanted I knew the
part I wanted I circled it I knew how I
was in a play and I went after this part
Longest Yard style American gangster
style all those movies I got with I said
the taping I went after it I called
producers
I called directors you know me I tell
you one time man yeah we don't call how
was calling producers I was seeing what
other projects producers didn't top and
the friends of the hairs yeah I [ __ ]
involve myself in this movie I want at
these three scenes then we're gonna
change my life it was a hotel clerk yeah
eight eight something look at his movies
eight something it was about him being
he's dying number four I'm just thinking
of number will slip I'll never forget
that I didn't get that movie in guys I
got no I don't know what depression is I
went into a coke for depression I get
depressed but you don't get depressed
well you know how about stuff like this
okay I wouldn't let myself get the press
but
I know it's percentages but for some
reason this one that's what I'll tell
you I can tell you all that Robin
started what movies did he make from mm
water alley man black to bad boys to
iRobot short to pitch hits was I am
Legend Hancock seven pounds seven pounds
ah what the body dies you lose seven
pounds oh yes I never heard of that one
yeah exactly it was it was gonna change
my whole [ __ ] life my whole [ __ ]
life when they told when I went in there
I bribed knew that I know you know you
know whines yeah I knew the script
inside of that that's amazing
I know Will Smith's mine I knew
everybody's lines in the [ __ ] movie
you had it I walked I was like I got
this I got this
and it was one of those movies that got
cast around on holiday or something so
it's like a break next one it sounds
like an independent project okay Will
Smith don't do nothing dependent they
pay him 20 well yeah but if it didn't ya
know it just didn't it just didn't hit
just interesting came out a weekend with
a Disney movie you got I see what you're
saying yeah marketing doesn't wasn't
done right nobody knew about it I didn't
lose what was the sequel to get shorty
yes the sequel to get shorty I lost that
role to a guy that died no he got they
did the movie and I loved them yeah yeah
don't get me cool be cool be cool
oh my god be cool I went down there I
read thought it was it was
what's-her-name Syst a partner from The
Sopranos oh okay the Georgene walkin I
went down there was a it was done by
Santa Monica hallway by Fort Street
I'll call it down walked in red with her
on the way back they beat me that's a
turnaround sir Walter's gonna be in an
hour he wants to read with you I read
with Travolta and then I came back again
and read with whoever else was the storm
was at that movie because they added
some Vince Vaughn I'm with Herman
keep going Cedric the Entertainer Andre
Benjamin Steven Tyler Robert pastor le
Robert pastor OE he died a week later
oh he's the one that got it yeah yeah
yeah he's an old he was a oh yeah every
he did uh he did the Arnold movie with
he was the one that was the witness
relocation plan in the Arnold movie
what's the one where Arnold finds people
with Vanessa Williams
oh what's that one I'm thinking
Terminator that's wrong nobody remembers
these [ __ ] people but anyway I
[ __ ] read for that with pastor Ali I
read for that which revolta I mean I
love how many things she read she called
me at the house and she told me how
great of a job was eraser eraser it was
disowned yes now I see yeah December 18
it was a Thursday and I knew this town
shuts down that Friday and I was going
to Sony to read for everybody for this
Oh for the oh I see what you mean yeah
yeah yeah and I had this backwards or
forward time yes I had the black velour
warm up with the gold chain the wife
beater top hat nah I kept switching I
kept switching outfits they're just
staring from looks oh yeah you know me
though I'm Way ahead of the [ __ ] fear
yeah yeah well this one I wanted to play
the guy like gangster would like a like
pastor Ali was gonna plant [ __ ] god I
hate breakfast went oh my sides put it
down a notebook wrote my lines down a
notebook [ __ ] win the shower come on
the shower I hear the phone ring [ __ ]
answer it's my agent I go what's up she
goes
I'm sorry they booked the roll out of
New York last night and just cry just
cry like this movie's gonna changed my
life Steven Tyler's yeah a reasonable
and will be bummed it did bomb because
it was horrible I just seen it on cable
dog but I never got all Vince Vaughn
they can't even remember it
yeah Vince Vaughn a bunch them just ruin
it so sometimes when you don't I learned
this from kind of the show sometimes
when you don't get something at the end
they're really doing you a [ __ ] favor
yeah it's a cliche to say like one door
closes another one opens but it's a real
thing like an offer I told him I told
him after the strike in 2007 all that
we're calling me where everybody wanted
to make a movie on YouTube
everybody youtube series oh yeah budget
is way up there now tube YouTube YouTube
one day I said you know what I'm not
doing these normal for a year people can
call me I will give you 200 a day it's a
you know no no no boom I got a call from
[ __ ] the Travolta the DeNiro
Stallone movie yeah and didn't do
nothing
but by me holding out oh yeah I proved
to myself and we go back to the universe
takes gas and yeah the universe will
take care of yourself if you stick to
your guns
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] well no matter
what my cousin works for Warner Brothers
it's all worth it selling them will do
second series yeah until then but in all
these people are gone now wait they
don't do not know more but the question
I want to say to you was how funny is it
that Sebastian hit yeah that whole
Italian who disappeared of comics yeah
Jimmy and Joey
wheels to be a Jimmy I just saw him I
really like I love them but I love them
but it was the night of a thousand we
know ah they tried everything everybody
try [ __ ] everything when she I
remember Jimmy and Joey were and I
forget which Joey or Jimmy he was on but
Jimmy Joey were in the are on stage and
dice was like you can't say oh that's my
thing like cuz they would tell a joke
and go oh and dice was like that's my
thing
and he's totally [ __ ] with that but
they went on stage doing the big and
they tell a joke and dice is sitting in
mitzi seat in the back of the LR and
you'd hear them like so whatever you
know why don't attend join the witness
protection no witness Oh like hey stop
and Andrew goes what I say and then they
to another joke it's right not to do it
with the L on the end of it oh my god it
was the saddest and greatest thing I've
ever seen cuz he was just [ __ ] with
them but it's not there to make sure
they wouldn't do it nobody gets that
dice is a [ __ ] goof that's right time
he was faltering
I was [ __ ] with all those guys for a
while he's the effects master and then
he called me the one-day Neapolitan I
told him I said [ __ ] Marino's doctor
when you it's a form of flattery get
over it
no he's not even Luka doing me that's
how I met advice Wow yes somebody Scott
Scott Scott de de Scott de scotch their
God they waited for 11and he dice
purposely called Scott told him to put
up Marino and Luca and then he was
revealed down there at 10:30 on a
Tuesday and he sat Danny so looking up
look at them dead doing me and you let
them do that
Luca would go in his pocket and take his
liner up to light a cigarette have a
flame at that barbecue wider yeah yeah
take it out light it but the funniest
line Luca would have is I don't know if
you guys know it I'm but Gambino captain
I used to be a hit man for the Gambino's
I can't tell you how many times people
came up with me
idiot and I love Luca I look I really I
miss Luca
me too I'm human forever I'm just
looking to put that whole Italian scene
but sometimes that Moreno would tell
people um the dice stole his act like
he's told club owners that recently and
I'm like what and I like Moreno like are
they he's funny he's he does his own
whatever he's you know he doesn't look
nice too my style is dice everybody Don
me but so did [ __ ] Rodney right and
so did Bill Hicks and so did Pryor
yeah so when you see me sometimes I feel
what I'm doing prior onstage I know it
when I catch myself
yeah I feel that way know exactly what X
would say I know is my door yeah well I
say those little tags at the end that's
Hicks
yeah I'm just emulating the Higgs it
wouldn't let you go down without a fight
he's bags at the end yeah that's at six
yeah Suze call you know I rare to rare
does that is the style it's it's and I
catch myself because I watched so long
twelve years at the store as a waitress
watch them so long sometimes I'll catch
myself like [ __ ] that's very I rarely
you know like don't say it like that see
how you say people watch the game
exactly but I do emulate people we do
look up to people Judy gold is one of my
favorites so you can see that I mean my
new favorite is Jessica curse him do you
know Jess oh my god I didn't say hello
because we wouldn't have to go up right
let us say hello she's very funny
God she was ripping up but she's a
lesbian
Yeah right she's a lesbian yeah but
she's Jersey girl yeah lays it down for
you she said it you know people tell me
I'm triggered I'm triggered from what
you said yeah have kids you'll get
triggered
all day yeah good
but she's Jesus brilliant she's just
always been and but I didn't know her
cuz she didn't come to LA that's my
other problem if you didn't come to the
Comedy Store
I really didn't know your standup you
know anyway so my influences are all
basically Comedy Store people you know
any man so it's some of its [ __ ] up
that's what Rogen's favorite thing was
is that you would come in and when I was
waiting tables
people would be like oh how's the show
gonna be tonight and I do like our and I
show them the lineup and I go right here
you're gonna want to go take a piss
out here after this guy you're gonna
want to shoot yourself in the face like
I would [ __ ] with people but they would
laugh and tip me more so I was working
the table not knowing it sooner I'm
saying like I was doing him but I didn't
know I was doing that but I was just
trying to make money so I was like yeah
you're gonna take a long walk around the
building because both of these are
terrible and they would always [ __ ]
at the end of the night be like you were
absolutely right that was awful i sat
through it I should have listened to you
I should have taken a break cuz the guy
after him or the girl after him was
great but that you know
Mitsy had her [ __ ] nuts that she
would just throw in there to [ __ ] with
people's got another one who would [ __ ]
with people on a regular basis like she
just she put a nonchalantly on I don't
know how you say anything do you
remember that [ __ ] guy he couldn't do
15 minutes he looked like a genie came
out of a bottle she a nonchalant male
his names on the wall hilarious she had
a couple of people he could do a solid
six that was a kid that wall like a
unitard Frank Lehrman he wouldn't talk
of lover man I loved there was another
guy lover man went up in a singlet
Wesleyan saying that yeah yeah and he
would play a paddle tennis ping Kong
whatever the [ __ ] ya know with himself
on stage so funny to hear this now cuz
for comics like me like this stores like
uh like heaven and to hear people doing
that up on the stores yeah
in his country he shoot in Germany
this guy's [ __ ] huge right I don't
have an email crazy [ __ ] with his hair
bro yes sweetheart
the like six weeks yeah cut months
no month so you just came in even spots
that we made but he was huge in Germany
I'm surprised there was more German
tourists I remember that not [ __ ] love
to war like a shiny shoe he would switch
it up a singlet the tiny suit all kinds
of [ __ ] he'd be like hey I don't know
you know whatever like that I don't know
but he'd be like I was in the hot tub
with girls party shorts and I'm like oh
that's great man II think now I'm gonna
go on state and then he wouldn't say a
[ __ ] word while he was on stage he
would just make noises or do weird [ __ ]
or play the [ __ ] table tennis she
loved him there was another guy she told
me was gonna be the next Jim Carrey and
then Lauren pelts the you know member
lauryn Ola wait one of my best friends
should we work there for six years
together
she backed Mitzi up she goes this guy is
gonna be huge I never saw him again he
was [ __ ] [ __ ] from the minute I
saw him but Mitzi was like that she like
that like bizarro that's what the main
room was for because she would have like
more of a show II kind of thing it would
be like a regular Santa then it'd be
like Janice Hart who was doing like song
parodies and Val Pappas and Monica
gayness that we're doing characters [ __ ]
like that
Frank lemon Noah Frankie pace Frankie
pace would do oils [ __ ] little put a
stupid [ __ ] on his head and dance around
then it would be dom i rera john
Mulrooney Sherri Shepherd Rita Jo you
know any mean like she always liked a
bizarre kind of eclectic comedy
taste she was [ __ ] nuts but some of
those people just disappeared a nun I
never saw him again I've no idea where
he is
he's probably running CIA or something
he was so [ __ ] aware that other kid I
can't think of his name I have no idea
what happened to him the next Jim Carrey
but she would do that she passed Jimmy
and Jolie
then she saw them again and she was like
oh no I messed up sorry but with
Sebastian he bombed on her showcase for
her he had just graduated
sandy seashores class and he didn't do
well in her graduation thing either
then showcase for mitts he didn't do
well she passed him I remember looking
at the paper like oh [ __ ] she's okay
cuz that guy didn't do well then she
kept putting them on kept put them all
moving him further back in the lineup
further back in the lineup you know he'd
be 1 a.m. - you know 1:30 late night
sometimes just the belly room you know
but she she kept him in the loop and
people were pissed like who [ __ ] is this
guy you know mitts he just passed him
because he's good-looking you know but
she did it I asked her I said did you
pass him cuz he was cute because she's
done that before
Luca you're welcome uh and so she did a
million times she goes no I don't like
that one I like that way and so three
years two years later we're sitting in
our Sebastian's [ __ ] annihilate and
she looked at me she goes I surprised
myself what they out one she saw
something I don't know what she saw but
sometimes you see it sometimes don't
everybody can have that one or two great
sets like there's comics I know that are
pretty awful but I've seen them have
great sets once at least that's the
lesson we learned from her that what you
walked in there you walked out a
different person if you [ __ ] with it and
he stuck with it and he stuck with it
Sebastian I mean cuz you're talking
about Sundays when he would he would
come in at like stage eleven twelve he
was a waiter right but he would have the
day off the day off but to sign up I'm
saying remember when they used to come
sign up on Sundays so he would I
see him in the parking lot doing it dad
what are you doing those bronzing up
while I wait to go on crossing up but he
would he would like lay out in the to
wait for the signup sheet to come down
sign up go to four seasons and come back
later that night for I think that you
got up the system so fast you become so
funny because you saw the proper way to
do it and you did you but got thrown to
the Wolves quick but you which is great
and you have to get thrown to the Wolves
quickly you have to yeah I would throw I
I'd throw people to the walls all the
time yeah cuz I want them to know yeah
time to time you need to get your own
tool and I look at those bite marks and
they told me to do better make sure you
go home and really think about what
you're doing what you like and if you
want to do that you want to do this and
this is it's a long ugly haul there's a
thousand people that want to be a comic
yeah doing it and doing it correctly
it's a whole nother story
and that's where we were lucky
yeah we were lucky yeah I didn't pay
attention I just put my head down and
kept going down there but you're one of
my favorites from the minute you walked
in like as far as you think because it
stays just [ __ ] fit who I was
but the story you mean yeah you're right
for me it's like a Holtzman thing just
like he just third day I was did call me
from my third set people came up to me
and said there's Mitzi singing yet
yeah the storm was made for a guy like
me I belong there that's why today I
don't go anywhere else like the Simone
would say the land of misfit toys is
what we all do at the combination you
know just water guns chill out man if
you don't belong there that's why I do
I'm not man you you belong at the improv
you find you really don't wait and
complain that you're not one place don't
nothing bothers you more than this to
read this there's a mill economy clubs
in LA and ninety six seven rooms go join
you
yeah you're Kia crying wasting time go
with
when you get that funny the time is
still fine that's right no fudge yeah
don't call you and even if you are that
like you think you're that funny which
is fine because a lot of people do think
that funny they work elsewhere like they
say you can't make it unless you're in
at the Comedy Store Mike was talking
about it all there's a million comedy
showcase seven years I don't know how
many times but stuff
Haman's shambling or dancing 19 was this
one crazy heaven Shandling her neck and
neck for not getting passed for the
seven year more every shilling and then
yeah he's yeah he's in a group with Gary
I'm Gary
I remember him God rest his soul he was
hosting the Emmys I think it was and he
was in the Comedy Store and he was the
me and mitts are walking down the hall
and she spotted him I didn't know always
him at first you know you walk it gets a
little darker and so and of course I'm
trying to probably save someone's job
while I'm walking on my club mates you
know they didn't mean it they just sat
down and you know they're human and you
know so and she see all Gary and she
yells he comes over and he a Sue's he
saw he automatically started sweating
hosting the Emmys
does that ever go away it didn't go away
with her no matter what
stay still had that beer remember ed
Ygritte like he came over he was talking
Gary sweating wiping his brow
yeah I'm hosting he's audience nice like
it was nothing like yeah good your
little gig you want to do a spot in your
no no he's just sweat I'm gonna go I
just need a friend it's so panicked and
he left but like I was thinking of like
Eddie Griffin and dice in the 90s they
had a big fight in the kitchen or maybe
it was mm it could have been mm because
I think Andrew and I maybe just started
dating or was right before so maybe it
was like early 2000s they had a big
fight
Mitsy came in she was like what happened
and I'm like I you know they just had a
stupid argument over stage time blah
blah it's no big deal I tried to squash
it I want to talk to
both of them so I'm like what are they
eight okay Teddy Griffin and Andrew Dice
Clay
remember did so they come in she's
sitting in the white couches remember in
the kitchen we had those white couches
and she would always sit on the far back
one so she could look at herself in the
mirror across I don't know if you knew
that but that's what she would do is she
would look at herself right so she
sitting on her bench these two come in
like schoolboys
I've never seen them like hey Mitty like
Olsen the leather jackets off Eddie's
big hats are off like nothing there were
just two kids afraid to get in trouble
with Mitzi shore and they both sat down
and she goes wide he happened and
they're like well yeah you you go you
two you two you tell it like I'm like
I'm watching these [ __ ] squirm
because this is how powerful this woman
is in their career and in what they want
to be accepted by it was the greatest
thing I ever seen I was like this is
[ __ ] awesome I don't understand I had
the same relationship with me I always
won oh you got you got you are good with
her yeah could you were funny I used to
get her before she could say yes to me
if I did something wrong I go up to her
hug talk to and then she got a week
later of course she's like Joey what I
say no you're not getting banned just
know you're I remember I was running
over in line at that but she loved it
because she knew you were part of her
like that kind of comic she liked it
it's a troubled soul and they got a lot
to say [ __ ] great
she loved been loved that long nobody
they accused me one time one of the
managers I dated a girl named Carol huh
so what I don't care of course Fred
Freddie had was started to blow up and
the white kid with the glasses his buddy
Oh Shaq Oh Shaq came to me one Freddy
Soto notion that you really like
you and I hey man I can't do this job
anymore do you mind driving two days a
week this Freddy was blowing up he was
opening for Carlos so now not only I
didn't know hey I was a telemarketer and
then hens Mitchell did away with the
telemarketing
me and Shama [ __ ] the guy that was
datin Kelly Kirsten yeah the driver cos
Phi cos I bet I started driving the bad
did you know that do you remember that
cuz I had to go get a tongue sandwiches
always that's her favorite what's that
what chin chin it's [ __ ] Chinese
chicken salad I used to have to go to
the hardware store
Oh Koontz she loved that I've only
admits the [ __ ] aisles are too small
but one day one day I actually went to
the bank get over
I took the hon John had to go right
through hi a spy
alright oh ho and they say none to me
the bank made the mistake and then
another time I would never steal from
the comedy store I already knew if I
wanted if you steal from it
there's no it's gonna come back it's not
coming back mm-hmm so this guy like
Carol
he would always flirt whatever I have
brought Carol I just say that I was just
giving this the guy the opportunity one
day he just came up to me go say men
there was a carton of Marlboro Reds
missing you gave me with a list Lee
first against me he just started on me I
think you robbed it did you rob and I go
why would I rob a car they say well I
work for Richie Shaw I still remember
the guys faces city managers manager and
this one the managers didn't matter
you're right managers didn't matter like
I've had people come up to me Oh my
manager I don't remember you yeah you
could smack that's how many I fired
three myself I was a waitress a waitress
he ran the place she Elinor really up on
it he got the ones guys he what a piece
of [ __ ] he got the one guys here they
were on it for about two or three weeks
they were on this thing with the [ __ ]
the carton of cigarettes and I swear to
God at the time I smoked camel whites
keep it there you know why would I steal
warmer all right so finally I got a call
from Mitch you this guy let's fix this
so I went down at five o'clock like I
was the meeting was for on a Friday no
cheese had to pick up checks anyway yeah
go pick up my check I went down and it
was mayhem and Belinda oh good stuff
what was her name last night oh the [ __ ]
cares what a piece of [ __ ] good stuff
cuz me and my wife we're trying to
figure out it I'll never forget that I
sat down as calm as I could yeah
I said Mitzi sure before I came here I
was a criminal this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
just like that I know he keeps [ __ ]
saying that I stole the pack of [ __ ]
carton of cigarettes Mitzi I'm looking
you in the eye telling you I didn't
steal the carton of cigarettes now I'm
looking you in the eye and if you say it
again and he went to say some I go don't
even say it off [ __ ] smack in the
[ __ ] face right here you [ __ ]
I just went off Mickey's [ __ ] just blue
yeah you could see the steam Hanukkah
bush was out she loved comics yeah up
for themselves haven't threatened give a
[ __ ]
take it I'll Beach in here you turn
[ __ ] [ __ ] is like all stop stop stop
anything you're not gonna touch me I'll
dial nine-one-one I go Mitzi you see we
got a deal with these [ __ ] [ __ ]
and now is it it was never mentioned the
guy got fired and shook my head piece of
[ __ ] where are you this weekend a
Harvey's comedy club Yeah right see you
there Thursday tonight through Sunday
you're [ __ ] beauty I am ma'am happy
you can make it through late I was in
the mood for family today I love you
thank you
I'm in the moon I just wanna talk to
family it's [ __ ] mid-september I'm
headed to Dallas it's old the [ __ ] out
which was San Antonio sold the [ __ ] out
the majestic data
yes Tech Dean is gone it's over the only
thing that's left in your [ __ ] future
is Chicago on September 27th and those
[ __ ] are going fast then after
that I got Kansas City October 11th I
forget the name of the theater and the
[ __ ] Paramount Dean and Denver we
just added a second show at 9:30 so
there you have other ones those the
dates yeah uncle Vinny's 18th Point
Pleasant September 18th and 21st and
then mr. and mrs. America with dice and
Roseanne the 19th and the 20th paramount
Long Island with dice and Roseanne and
hard rock Atlantic City with dice around
and kill also the roar comedy club in
Springfield Massachusetts anybody got
some different artists listen don't be
[ __ ] go to my goddamn well I really
want you to go see dice and Roseanne
that sounds like a [ __ ] great great
it sounds like a great show I'm happy of
being a part of that before I leave a
real quick word from our sponsors Dollar
Shave Club listen as you guys know when
this podcast started we've been with
Dollar Shave Club member for years I
love them why because every month you
get a box in the mail with all the
essentials raises toothpaste shampoo and
the works it's a no-brainer if you
really think about it no more running
from drugstore to pay premium for things
you use every day with Dollar Shave Club
you get everything you need at a fair
price and Dollar Shave Club is way more
than just raises they got you covered
from head to toe everything you need to
shower shave style your hair brush your
teeth and even wipe your buck with the
one wipe Charlies who's better than they
are nobody keep your mother clean that's
the model of the church but that's not
all smelly throwing some sea spray
deodorant
frizzy hair they got a beautiful pomade
hand cream hair gel and a half pace no
excuses gotta update
they even got cologne and you could try
it all with the specialized trial kits
or the combination that works
for you plus they'll keep you stocked on
a schedule that works for you whether
that's once a month or a few times a
year you can't beat that all right
though right now the church family you
can put the quality of Dollar Shave
club's products to the test with their
ultimate starter sets they basically got
everything you need for an amazing
shower shave and clean teeth the best
part is you can try each set for just
five dollars five dollars that's it
after that the restock box ships regular
sized products at granular prices get
your ultimate starter set for just five
hours at dollarshaveclub.com search
again that's dollarshaveclub.com slash
church the church is also brought to you
by what time is it it's for baby back to
work back to school back to the new you
it's time to grow up and get a real
watch I got my beautiful Vince arrow on
right now I got another one at the house
the rose on black or the rose on brown
but I'm waiting for the the strap to
come in so I just used this one I've had
this one for about a year it works it's
beautiful its stylish and lets people
know I ain't [ __ ] around
they got gorgeous watches like mine you
elevate your game with the Saros
handcrafted luxury watches these are
high-quality watches that look like you
drop to ten thousand dollars but all
this arrow you get to look at an
unbelievable price and if you want to
charge up your look all the wristbands
are interchangeable baby you don't
believe me well over 16,000 five-star
reviews don't lie if you want a watch
that looks like a million bucks and it's
made with exceptional craftsmanship and
it's a good value you know me then cero
is the watch for you
listen church go to this arrow calm
right now listen Wilma do Fiat I'm gonna
get you a nice new watch with 15% off
your order
15% that's Fitz arrow VI n see ero
watches dot-com slash Church
Preston Koecher to check out the 15% off
your order
you understand me Plus worldwide
shipping is always free one more time
for the cheap seats
Vince arrow watches comm press coats
were Church slur CH Church don't waste
any more time get yours today
hello tonight you got football [ __ ]
tomorrow you got [ __ ] baseball
Saturday you got college football Sunday
you got pro football Monday you got bro
football you got baseball it's getting
close towards the end the [ __ ] the
divisions are getting tight everybody
wants that [ __ ] wild card
it's time to make money that's what it's
all about you're like betting sports
I'll tell you where you put your money
down my bookie dot AG if you're trying
to bet on the NFL baseball ballot or UMC
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do my
bookies got it they got better
incentives and more lines than any other
sports book period do me a favor they're
gonna double your first deposit today
use promo code Church to get a hundred
percent bonus on your initial deposit up
to $1,000 what was that Joey initial
deposit up to $1,000 visit my bookie dot
AG today
that's my bookie that AG today and don't
forget to use promo code Church when
creating your account that claimed the
bonus and remember tomorrow check my
Instagram at Matt flavors world I'll be
dropping a little video with my pics and
I'll teach you how to make bets on my
book here right you'll be saying Jesus
[ __ ] Christ uncle Joey's a savage
let's win some money I want to thank my
bookie I want to thank Vince Aero
watches and I want to thank
dollarshaveclub.com or thank Elinor but
most importantly I want to thank you
savages for always support me and having
my back you're a great bunch of
[ __ ] and I love you stay black
have a great weekend
we'll be back Tuesday morning ready Iraq
tip top Magoo Dallas I'll see you Friday
night
San Antonio I'll see you saturday
night I love you [ __ ] the
church what's happened now kick this
melee